battle of the sexes wide-release about
the Bobby Riggs Billie Jean King match
for the ages it is a great movie and it
stars in part
Elizabeth shoes here in the studio good
to see you that's so ok I guess let's
just talk about cocktails you set the
stage Mike I mean you you loved that
movies excited well first of all is that
it was a movie with Tom Cruise okay and
my brothers love Tom Cruise so like as a
Top Gun or something like that yeah so I
had some credibility in my household
because I was at a Tom Cruise movie so
you got cool you got points yes major
points how many brothers do you have
3 3 yes so you're the are you they loan
I'm the second oldest I had some power
but you the loan girl yeah so I played a
lot of sports growing up what'd you play
soccer okay yeah I played on all boys
teams rich karate kid she plays soccer
oh yeah I had to pretend to be bad I
pretend I didn't know what I was doing
but I was better than Ralph Macchio and
probably a karate to Train I'm not sure
much better if I had trained that wasn't
part of your role in the film what was
that like for you at being a new actress
in the world and getting to be in the
Karate Kid right off the bat what was
that like for you Elizabeth um why I've
been in the business for about five
years before that so it wasn't this
sudden okay
experience I was the Burger King girl I
did a lot of commercials I say slowly
slowly slowly learned my way into it so
you had it your way is that what you're
saying yes that was was that the phrase
back in the time and your way special
orders how I sing that no it was a
different knows Burger King beat frying
nearly three to one and it goes once a
Burger King spokesperson always abroad
you never can get that out of here huh
so so you were then you just showed up
on the set of Karate Kid did you have
any idea how special that movie
was when you were nearly none I was
worried I thought it sounded a little
strange the Karate Kid yeah
and Ralph's being Ralph I didn't think
you have any credibility as a karate
expert it is what it is no it was
amazing though to see that movie
actually stand the test of time all my
kids have watched it I love what it says
about sports and about the relationship
between Miyagi and Daniel is so
beautiful so there's so much that's good
about it have you shown your kids
adventures in babysitting I have yes as
what like a teachable lesson or
something like or something like when
when mom and dad go out you need yeah
you need to behave yeah my my my
youngest really likes the line don't f
with the babysitter okay how old is you
I have a 19 year old who just went to
college Daniel okay I'm 16 yes girls an
11 year old girl okay yeah hello laughs
leets by the way so my next question
elisabeth shue here on the Rich Eisen
show so how are you as a youth sports
parent how were you elisabeth shue at
these games I'm trying to be better with
each kid I think with miles I was a
little bit intense that the older mom
yeah he was a soccer player second
Stella she's a gymnast and then Agnes is
a tennis player so I've got all three of
my favorite sports covered no kidding
soccer Jim I was a gymnast I played
soccer
uh-huh and now I'm a tennis player now
you're now you're a tennis player for
sure all the sexes again in theaters
near you but so were you about their
play I I was always very supportive of
their play but no just the reffing at
times it's really difficult to tennis
tournaments when your kid gets cheated
those kind of moments I feel like I'm a
little too stressed out after like take
walk around the field sometimes or walk
away from the court right but never
about my kids now I'm fair I'm a really
good sports mom when it comes to
encouraging your kids but did it did an
umpire ever come up to you and say look
you know yeah I got thrown off the field
once
Elizabeth you should have been maybe
once or twice but now I've never been
three but no ever came up to you like
look I know I blew the call but I gotta
tell you I love Jim leaving Las Vegas
then never did anything like that ever
happened no it was yeah that would be a
good way to get a rough on your side
back yeah hey look look here's my IMDB
page why don't you treat my kid a little
bit better I want to take a 60-second
break come back and talk about battle of
the sexes whom you've spent some time
with Billie Jean King I had this whole
through all the promotion and obviously
the shooting of the film so we'll talk
about that and a little bit more of your
filmography and we've got Elisabeth Shue
here back in 60 seconds and then of
course your phone calls still here on
this Thursday show on the Rich Eisen
show don't go anywhere
[Music]
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
Elizabeth Shue is here in person she
plays the wife of Bobby Riggs in battle
of the sexes Emma Stone as Billie Jean
King spectacular yeah perfect
you can't imagine anybody but her and
you can't imagine anybody with Steve
Carell fur as Bobby Riggs he is
spectacular
as him and they both look like it
although I got to tell you just having
been fresh off a lala land I didn't
really think when I heard okay Emma
Stone's gonna be Billie Jean King yeah
that could be pulled up she looks just
like yeah and she gained 15 pounds of
muscle weight the physicality the walks
yeah yeah she was working out she was
doing push-ups like between shots she
put on her tennis yes Steve worked as
tennis for six months they were really
really dedicated and it shows the tennis
in this movie is so good
and I care a lot about tennis so you are
you're a tennis maven player or an
aficionado now are you just tucked up
the sport I started when I was 37 and I
kind of wanted to train like a
professional to see how good I could
become so 15 years in I don't look like
a professional although I look somewhat
like I could have played college but the
most important thing is I can beat my
brothers so let's just throw Andrew out
for yes I can beat him I can beat
straight sets straight sets uh yeah yeah
what's your shot cross-court what do you
got um I was really good forehand
anywhere can you uncork it Federer like
like when you're not expecting and all
of a sudden Elizabeth she just takes the
rap I love it how did you prepare for
the role of Bobby Riggs his wife how did
you do that for this movie I mean that's
got to be a heck of a role to undertake
with Bobby Riggs being well you know
Bobby Riggs well I really felt like my
reason for being in the movie was to
reveal who Bobby Riggs actually was as a
human and he was somebody who was much
more complicated than people understood
he was actually lovable and had a
beautiful spirit and a kind of a
showmanship to him he wasn't the evil
sort of masochistic chauvinist pig that
they made him out to be so that was an
act was that something exactly it was a
way to get attention he was kind of
desperate and I think that my character
loved and wanted to take care of that
part of him mm-hmm
but he did not throw that match let's
just talk about that no there is no way
because he if he had won the match he
would have played Chris Evert for a
million dollars and that's what he was
all about making money and once he lost
that match fair and square
it was over for him he was depressed for
months and years his coach Lonnie
trained Bobby Riggs and I talked to him
for a long time and there's no way
because we were discussing that man I
think there's some guys out there that
really still want to you know we that
and it's just it's just not cool well I
agree first of all no I agree because no
because I it is it is so important still
to this day 2017 yes about what happened
in the Astrodome on that day yes because
of the way people have been revering
Billie Jean King and win or lose she
still had deserved
everybody's reverence to say the least
yeah but the fact that anybody would sit
there and say that Bobby Riggs tossed it
yeah and she did not yeah yeah I know
also what's hard is that she never she
never was saying you know we're better
than guys she was saying we deserve
respect his athletes and he was
disrespecting her he was 55 years old
and challenging her to a match when she
was number one in the world and and she
always says I loved him so much that's
why I beat him she respected him and so
she wanted equal respect that's it
and there still even a conversation
about just happened recently where John
McEnroe said that that Serena would lose
to the 76 man in the world yeah well I
mean he was being asked a direct
question and I guess he gave an out he
didn't just bring it up unsolicited ly
just right but they but still you know
drove people nuts and Serena did win the
Australian Open this year I believe
brockman
eight months pregnant at the time I
think we're showing it open yeah yeah
yeah so try that on for size yeah
let's see you have a living being inside
while you actually beat the living crap
out of an opponent for four for a title
elisabeth shue here on the Rich Eisen
show what was it like being around
Billie Jean King had you ever met her
before before she's amazing she is so
real and so generous she's like the kind
of person who's always looking out for
other people she is no interest in
talking about herself she just wants to
make sure everyone else getting enough
attention what do you mean by that
well like we sit in panels you know
sometimes we're doing question answers
and if no one's asking someone at the
end of the line a question she's like I
just wanted to tell you how amazing he
is in his part she's always worried
about everyone else not herself and
she's she's so cool she's she's always
giving you advice on your tennis well
especially maybe come on here so much
got a coffered up what did you give you
advice on your 10-second serve mental
thing because you need to get your
second serve in no it was actually where
you're supposed to hit the ball because
I was sort of trying I was trying to go
like and slice the ball on this side
she's like oh what do you want doing is
this for your first every second serve
is like second
oh you gotta hit it right here and you
got to go up across you got to go off to
the side and she's just is so a such a
great teacher and a mentor and she's
like the coach of the world are you
coachable though did it improve your
second sir yes it did I am coachable
very so now you could spin that puppy in
and and and win points on your second
serve yeah and she's also obviously
amazing it dealing with pressure that
match 90 million people watched that
match was there in a tuxedo calling it
yeah yeah I mean this was this was the
whole country stop - why did I mean you
take a look again at that right now
Elizabeth you here in Norwich Ozzie Joe
you look right now at the top ten most
watched television events okay nine of
them are Super Bowls the finale of mash
is still in that mix yeah so but no 90
million people to sit around for a
sporting event yeah nobody does that
anymore other you know the Super Bowl
yep that's about it imagine the pressure
walking out there knowing that all the
there's
women was literally on the line three
sets to yeah he challenged her best of
five right that's unbelievable
that is great and so but to get tennis
advice from Billie Jean I know I know
crazy I'd be like it's a little bit
better than getting I guess karate
lessons from Ralph Macchio and again
Steve Carell he couldn't be like one of
the nicer guys he is so good hey I mean
the number of times he's transformed
himself for an acting role Foxcatcher he
was in you know played a lunatic in
Foxcatcher
and now he's transformed himself as
bobby riggs yeah and he has no ego
that's really nice none he's very
generous very open he's more humble than
anyone on the set that's cool that's
great
well Brockman I'm gonna give you the
floor to ask Elizabeth Shue a question
about her movie career I know that you
wanted to ask a question so go for it I
mean we covered a lot of them so yes
we've got babysitting I think you like
The Karate Kid though no you like
cocktail no I like cocktail I'm a huge
I'm a huge cocktail fanboy you just I
put you in the batter's box you know I
can't do any of that scan try no come on
you're really drinking during the movie
is that a vinegar Oh were we really
drinking no not at all shaking no can
you flip a bottle I can you really
here's Elizabeth you I've given her a
water bottle it's about what would you
say about half-full
right there half half full there you go
[Laughter]
where you flip it on its thing did you
flipped it up and then he poured it then
he poured it I know but I thought you're
talking about that every with all the
what the kids are doing what is your
what what is your drink of choice ah I
like a good mojito
mohei
yeah okay kind of a girly drink no
that's that's okay a little bit no a
little bit of uh I don't know a little
bit of money you don't know what's in a
mojito now well I mean there's a spice
to it there's a mint well sugar little
mint yeah there you go
Senate cocktail again Elizabeth I have
been a fan of yours for for uh for quite
some time and it's thrilled to have you
here on show know you don't do a lot of
these shows so thanks for I like sports
so they're perfect for me next time back
next talk sports
anytime next time sir certainly since
certainly since poor Ralph Macchio I
cannot great athlete come on
wait you just said he wasn't a great
loves a great acting that you have done
in your career who knew that the best
acting you did is you played worse than
your level of soccer that's your best
acting perhaps them right out of the
gate
don't go anywhere we're gonna stick for
the television audience Elizabeth Shue
one of the things that you mentioned in
your career we we we have and we're
gonna show it to you we're gonna relive
a little bit down memory lane with
Elizabeth you will come back and
describe for the radio audience what
we've done as we get set for a big
Thursday night football game between the
Packers and the Bears the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy